dave rubin is the host of the reuben
report he joins us now all right so
let's go through it they have actually
almost 567
000 signatures much of the opposition uh
against the la liberal d.a stems from
his progressive directives that critics
blame for an uptick in crime meaning he
emboldens criminals they say that no
longer they fear harsh consequences from
the da's office essentially he brought
this onto himself
yes he absolutely did there's no doubt
about it let's not forget that george
gascon before he was the d.a of los
angeles was the d.a of san francisco and
everyone knows certainly everyone on fox
knows what has happened to the dystopian
nightmare of a city that san francisco
now is so he destroyed san francisco and
now he has spent the last couple of
years destroying los angeles by the way
he replaced
a woman by the name of jackie lacy who
was the first black female d.a that los
angeles had ever had i don't really care
about someone's gender or skin color
related to all of this but the
progressives decided to get rid of the
black female d.a who actually was doing
a pretty decent job and was a moderate
from 2012 to 2020 and replace her uh you
know with an older white guy those are
their rules not our rules but yes crime
is up homelessness is up drug use is up
it's one of the many reasons that me and
about 300 000 other people
fled california i fled los angeles
specifically and i now live in the free
state of florida but this is what
happens in progressive politics if you
destroy things which progressives always
do you fail up let's not forget gavin
newsom was the mayor of new york of san
francisco and now he is the governor of
california and he's brought those same
policies
across the state perfect example
actually i'm glad you mentioned of
failing up and and gascona's basically
emboldened criminals um by ways such as
not seeking cash bail and sentencing
enhancements and if you look at la crime
stats and you just touched on it a bit
everything
is up i mean everything from murder
robberies aggravated assault burglaries
theft now many are outraged as gascone
defended his policies after it was
revealed a suspect who killed two el
monte police officers last month was
actually out on probation at the time
after getting a plea from his office
these are two
men in blue who would be alive today if
it not be for gascon
well it's incredible because not only
these people all about defunding the
police but they're also about constantly
demonizing the police and then what
happens is you are going to get less
qualified people that are willing to
become police officers so it's a
cascading effect that completely
decimates a city's ability to police
itself properly and then you get this
fleeing effect and people don't want to
live around crime i can tell you that
for the two years the last two years
that i lived in los angeles during the
pandemic and the summer of peaceful
riots or whatever was going on there was
no faith no one that i knew had any
faith that if someone broke into your
house or if you were mugged on the
street or whatever it might be that
anyone would help you that there was any
chance that something
that the system would allow for someone
to come in a police officer and do the
right thing so this is what progressives
want and it's going to just continue so
i hope that the recall goes through i i
campaigned heavily to get gavin newsom
recalled obviously that didn't work out
as i would have wanted uh but i hope
that the recall goes through let's not
forget also chester boudine who is
another far left woke progressive uh d.a
in san francisco now he just got
recalled but the question is okay so you
recall these guys can you get someone
better actually to do it i don't know
i'm not sure there's any worse but
that's just i'm just saying uh dave
rubin thank you very much appreciate it
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell